Good morning Hank, it's Wednesday.
It is morning, but it is once again night-morning,
as you can see - oh look!
Jupiter!
All right Hank, it is nearly dawn in Roscoe,
New York.
Readers of the book will likely know from
the setting that it's a pretty serious day,
so I don't think I'm gonna be messing around
too much with Nat and Cara today.
Instead, let's talk about the Project for
Awesome.
Cara: Hiiiiiiii!
So Hank, the Project for Awesome -
C &others: Hiiiiii!
(laughter)
So -
Hiiii!
so -
so
Hiiii!
So Hank, the Project for Awesome is a -
So Hank, the Project for Awesome is a
hiiiii!
That's Nat Wolff, who plays Q in the movie,
and, um, John Lennon, who plays Margo Roth
Spiegelman.
Nat: I'm improvising now.
(Laughter from John).
Cara: Heeey Macarena!
To the left!
One maca-two-maca-three-macarena, nanananana,
heeey macarena!
John: Right!
So the Project for Awesome is an annual charity
event in which the Nerdfighter community tries
to decrease world suck and increase world
awesome.
Nat: Uh, the Project for Awesome will be on
December 12th and 13th, which is actually
4 days away from my birthday.
4 and 5 days away from my birthday.
When's your birthday?
December 17th.
That's when the Project for Awesome usually
is, but we had to move it because it's the
end of the Paper Towns shoot.
Cara: Because it's his birthday!!!!
Nat: Yeah, it's my birthday!
John: Yeah, we gotta focus on Nat's birthday
that day.
Yay!
Nat: Yeah, project for Nat.
I thought this change might be better received
if it came from, you know, Nat and Carr - oh
- this just got so weird.
I'm having such an unpleasant experience.
So we're moving the Project for Awesome to
December 12th mostly because of the Paper
Towns shoot but also because of Nat's birthday.
I'm sorry about that, but I, I really want
to be part of it.
But Hank, we also want to talk to Nerdfighteria
about maybe doing other things differently,
beginning with comments.
So the Project for Awesome started out in
2007 with YouTubers making videos about, like,
charity, instead of, you know, cats on Roombas
or whatever.
This is back when people discovered YouTube
videos primarily on, like, the "Most Discussed
Page" or the "Top Rated Page."
Nerdfighteria came together to essentially
hijack YouTube's algorithm.
And that was amazing, back when those pages
existed.
But then, YouTube made comments progressively
less important to discovery.
Basically, comments spamming just doesn't
work anymore.
I dunno where to vlog from so I think I'll
go to this creepy abandoned building.
So the other challenge that we have is that
traditionally, 100% of the Project for Awesome's
money goes to charities chosen by Nerdfighteria
at projectforawesome.com.
So this is a great system, but two things:
first, it's hard to get, like, matching money
from wealthy private donors.
And second, because we're all always so busy
comment-spamming, I think that sometimes there
isn't enough attention paid to the actual,
like, voting for charities.
So here is my proposal, and Nerdfighteria,
I want your feedback about this, any new ideas
you might have...
The first day of the Project for Awesome,
we raise money for three organizations that
are known to be excellent and efficient when
it comes to combating global poverty and disease.
This will allow us to get a lot of matching
donations, like potentially hundreds of thousands
of dollars, and also to decrease a known cause
of world suck.
And then the second day of the Project for
Awesome will be all about raising money for
charities chosen by Nerdfighteria, and instead
of comment-spamming, we'll have, like, meaningful
discussions in comments of Project for Awesome
videos.
So to summarize, Hank, here is my proposal:
December 12th and 13th instead of December
17th and 18th.
On December 12th, at noon Eastern, everyone
who wants to uploads a video about a charity
of their choice.
Members of the Nerdfighter community try to
watch as many of those videos as possible,
have substantive discussions in comments,
and then all of Nerdfighteria votes carefully
and thoughtfully for their favorite charities
at projectforawesome.com.
All of the money raised after the first day
of the Project for Awesome will go to those
charities, all of the money raised on the
first day that are well-regarded in the field
of global health and poverty.
And I can't decide if I should go in this
door.
I kind of want to.
Oh, it's a bathroom!
Oh, it's quite lovely.
We've experimented a lot with the format and
scope of the Project for Awesome over the
years, but one thing has never changed: it
is my favorite time of year to be a Nerdfighter,
and I can promise you: this year, the perks
are going to be amazing.
I'm going to go back to the movie set, I will
see you- this is the last time I get to say
this, it's kind of a bummer- tomorrow.